les clients profitent à nouveau de
l'auberge du manet depuis le 23 novembre
depuis mars dernier l'établissement
accuse près d'un million d'euros de
perte de chiffre d'affaires on est sur
une occupation de trois ou quatre
chambres par jour quelquefois 6
mais encore une fois on veut être là on
le veut on veut exister être vivant par
rapport à nos clients les clients ce
sont des majoritairement des français
puisque les gens de voyage plus normal
entre avec beaucoup de d'allemand
d'anglais d'italien espagnol avec ses
crises bien sûr on n'a plus personne
mais encore une fois on s'adapte pour le
2ème confinement isabelle bianchi a
choisi de proposer de la vente à
emporter quatre salariés l'accompagnent
dans l'activité à saint lambert des bois
aussi on a fait le choix de rester
ouvert en temps normal 80 % de la
clientèle les professionnels au mois de
novembre le chiffre d'affaires stagne
autour des 10%
nous sommes restés ouverts m'a déjà pour
morale parce que fermer un établissement
on a notre restaurant qui est fermé en
ce moment je peux vous dire voir un
établissement vide c'est d'une tristesse
incroyable
le personnel est très démotivés et puis
surtout commence vraiment à souffrir
aussi de 7,2 se confie deuxième
confinement et on est restés ouverts
pour le peu qu'on fait ça paye ou un peu
de facture électrique un peu de factures
à droite à gauche bas c'est toujours ça
sylvie et jean françois anglars tiennent
la boutique depuis le mois de mars les
six employés sont en chômage partiel le
moment est plutôt à la patience pour que
cette célèbre phrase puisse reprendre
tout son sens